are you like me jeff goldblum maybe we
share an interest in
[Music]
monsters fireworks magic motorcycles
dogs
want to take some photos with him
[Laughter]
we like to go out into the forest and
look for things that may very well not
exist we build our own drone light shows
oh that's a jellyfish there some
magicians like to blur the line
what what what
amazing
my acting life caused me to seek
openness and interest in the unseen
there's always a moment of fear
oh wow
it's just the unknown i guess am i going
to be 100 safe you're going to be like
99.8 percent
there goes nothing i love to learn about
everything
this is terrible
really what makes us special as people
is that we have specific abilities to
tune into others and cooperate and
collaborate boy i'm getting a lesson in
a lot of things i'm starting in first
grade in a lot of areas hi jeff wow eat
my dust we'll see who'll be done
sometimes life's most important moments
demand
courage
the journey is it not the destination
enjoy the ride
gets ten gold blooms out of a possible
10 gold wounds that's my highest
possible rating
[Music]